allerdings teure mal fahne und tut mir
leid dass das so lange gedauert hat aber
jetzt gibt es das dritte sommerloch
dieses mal habe ich leider keine
instagram bilder von euch gestoppt aber
eins muss ich sagen ich hatte euch
instagram gebeten dass ihr meiner besten
freundin auf ihrem profil schreibt dass
sie mich in berlin besuchen kommen soll
weil sie es nicht machen möchte
sie sagt sie hat keine zeit aber sie hat
über 300 kommentare von euch bekommen
und dafür danke ich euch und wenn das
mal nicht eine geile community aktion
war weiß ich auch nicht also super
aktuelle sachen zu denen ich etwas sagen
will
auch wenn es keinen interessiert die
flüchtlingssituation in deutschland ich
möchte jetzt keine genauen angaben dazu
machen denn es gibt so viele
spekulationen und meinungen im internet
wo ich manchmal selber nicht ganz
hinterher komme oder nicht weiß ob ich
mir eine meinung bilden kann und was
glauben kann und was nicht dann wird
darüber spekuliert ob sie wirklich
flüchten weil sie angst um ihr leben
haben oder weil es doch nur
wirtschaftlich ist und das ist ja so
viele sind und ich hab nur eine meinung
dazu und die geht an all die menschen
die der meinung sind sie freue sich dass
doch nur im schlaraffenland gut gehen
lassen habt ihr irgendetwas dazu
beigetragen dass ihr in deutschland
geboren wurde habt ihr für den wohlstand
dieses landes gesorgt ich denke nicht
also hört doch einfach auch so zu tun
als ob nur ihr das glück eines schönen
lebens verdient hätten ganz ehrlich
niemand flüchtet aus langeweile
aha jetzt bitte irgendwas schönes
favoriten
ich habe einen song wieder für mich
entdeckt und zwar ozean von tommy
blackout ist perfekt für diese der
sommer geht gerade zuende stimmung und
ich schaue mir das musikvideo einfach
immer wieder an weil ist es einfach
super finden wenn jedes noch nicht kennt
könnte ich hier oben mal drauf klicken
und euch auch in den ozean treiben
lassen
mein zweiter favorit ist ein video vom
guten alexy vecsey
das video zeigt den alltag von einem
youtuber und ich glaube das ist eher so
eine zukunfts projektion also was später
mal sein könnte mit youtube oder mit
youtube an wie sie wie sie handeln und
des videos einfach gänsehaut pur also
boah jungs toll an darüber nachzudenken
ob du alles so richtig tust videos tust
wie ich das gerade mache und also echt
applaus alexy vecsey und wie gehabt wenn
ihr es nicht kennt einmal drauf klicken
oder in der infobox coup aus der youtube
meine erste geschichte aus der youtube
welt ist er eine eigenwerbung bzw eine
bittere vor einiger zeit waren wir mit
studio 71 auf dem splash dort haben wir
zum einen das festival genossen und zum
anderen hat auch ein paar videos
produziert dieser videos ist ein
punchline quiz mit kelly und mir ich
weiß nicht wie du dir uns kennt aber wir
sind jetzt nicht gerade hip hop profi
und das hat die community vom splash mac
auch ganz schnell gemerkt und uns ein
bisschen geld würde ich mal sagen also
viele hip hop menschen auf youtube sind
nicht gerade nett und vielleicht ist der
eine oder andere ja bereit mal auf
dieses video zu klicken und ein nettes
kommentar zu schreiben und vielleicht
auf dem daumen nach oben zu geben
vielleicht könnten wir ja so eine
gegenveranstaltung
ich würds feiern ganz ehrlich wer das
plötzlich so positiv bewertet wird und
kunst ihre sachen man sich leute noch
mehr aufregen und wir wollen jetzt wenn
sich leute aufregen also los danke
zweites thema und da geh ich bin
wirklich nicht stolz drauf aber ich fand
es so unterhaltsam wie sich auf twitter
gebrieft haben gebrieft mit bvh es fängt
damit an dass ungedanken unterstellt hat
dass sie gar nicht mehr mit ihm zusammen
sondern somit um katar unternahmen die
sich so bisschen gestritten und dann
haben die alle so gemeine sachen gesagt
und da geht immer gesagt hier ist doch
dann begann das schnitzel es jedoch zum
kopf gestiegen und dann hat ein paar
tage später ein video hochgeladen wo er
wegen schnitzel mit ihrem foto macht das
kann ich wirklich ganz ehrlich meine
meinung dazu ich glaube nicht dass dani
und timo noch zu
sind aber es verkauft sich gut und das
ist doch das wichtigste
kommen wir nun zur trainerfrage
ich hab euch gefragt was das
umfassendste was man zu dramatischer
musik sagen kann also los maestros ich
esse gerne waschlappen
coop sind ich mag züge der übrigens oma
ist tot
ja
blutige hannah köpf
schatz war mitzufahren möbel kaufen
obwohl die süße melodien
ich glaube ich kriege meine tage
klingeling
hier kommt der 1
penis wolltest du das noch essen in
italien schon in justine typischer
kurzem kasten cambridge ist das tut
zurück cosmic chicks nach spannender
sollen die renten aus ahorn abzuschicken
sollte das wasser im sommerloch bis zum
nächsten mal ich hoffe ein bisschen
schneller